- [Instructor] In this video,
we're gonna start thinking
about what it means
for something to be a
multiple of a number.
So, we're asked,
which of the following
numbers is a multiple of nine?
So, pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
All right, now let's do it together.
And one way to think about a multiple,
a multiple is a number that you can get to
by multiplying the
number, in this case nine,
by a whole number.
So we could figure out
the multiples of nine
by skip counting, that's one way to do it.
So you could go from nine,
and then you add nine
to that, you get to 18.
You add nine to that, you go to 27.
You add nine to that, you
are going to get to 36.
You add nine to that, 45.
Add nine to that, 54.
Add nine to that, 63.
Add nine to that, you get 72.
Add nine to that, you get to 81.
And we could keep going.
But to figure out whether
these are multiples,
you really just have to say, hey,
are any of these numbers in this list?
Now, if one of these
numbers are larger than 81
we would have to keep
going to see it's included.
But we can see that 46 sits
between two multiples of nine.
46,
that sits closer to 45
but it sits in there,
it sits between two multiples.
So that's not going to be a multiple.
Another way to think about it is,
for something to be a multiple,
if you divide by nine,
you're not going to get a remainder.
But if you divided 46 by nine,
you are going to get a remainder.
You're not going to be able
to divide nine into it evenly.
So I am just going to,
I'm going to take that
one out of the contention.
77 is right over here,
it's between 72 and 81.
Once again, it's between two
multiples but not a multiple.
39 is between 36 and 45,
so not a multiple, between two multiples.
Rule that out.
And we can see very clearly
that 18 is a multiple.
If I was doing this on my own,
I would just maybe be
skip counting in my head.
I'd be going, nine, all
right I don't see a nine.
18, oh, I see an 18, there you go.
Specially if I'm only
going to pick one choice.
Let's do another example.
Which of the following shows
only multiples of eight?
So, pause this video and think about that.
All right, well, I could do
it choice by choice here.
So, let's see.
This first one, is four
a multiple of eight?
Well, four, it can divide into eight.
We could say that eight
is a multiple of four,
but four is not a multiple of eight.
What whole number am I
going to multiple eight by
to get to four?
So we can rule this out.
And you can think about
what they're showing here.
These are actually multiples of four,
not multiples of eight.
We can skip count here.
Four, eight, 12, 16, 20, 24, 28.
These are multiples of four,
not multiples of eight.
Some of the multiples of four
are also multiples of eight.
Eight is a multiple of eight,
16 is a multiple of eight,
24 is a multiple of eight,
but not all of the multiples
of four are multiples of eight.
And I think you might be
seeing a little pattern here,
which ones are multiples of eight.
Now, what about this
choice right over here?
16 is eight times two.
24 is eight times three.
32 is eight times four.
40 is eight times five.
In fact, we can skip count.
Eight then 16, 24, 32, 40, then
48, 56, so on and so forth.
But these are all multiples of eight,
so I like this choice.
And then over here,
one, two, four, and eight.
Well, these are showing numbers
that can be divided into
eight without a remainder.
You could think of them
as factors of eight.
You could say, hey,
I could multiply one
times eight to get eight.
I could multiple two
times four to get eight.
But these are not multiples of eight.
What whole number can I
multiply eight by to get one
or to get two or to get four?
In general, your multiples of a number
are going to be that
number or larger than it.
I was about to say that
number or multiples of it
but then I realized
I can't use multiples to define multiples.
It would be that number
or larger numbers than it.
And if you were to skip
count with that number,
you would hit all of the multiples.